[Musique]
le maraîcher voisin foumico et Anthony
Maubert viennent choisir leur légume et
leur fleur
c'est agréable de voir ce qui est
produit dans le jardin et on respecte au
moins les saisons parce que les saisons
c'est pas seulement quatre saisons c'est
que ces journaliers toujours c'est
différent puis tous les matins on vient
chercher nos légumes frais que Massato
va nous cueillir donc c'est un plaisir
de travailler des produits qui qui vont
tout de suite du jardin à l'assiette et
l'assiette justement n'est pas loin leur
restaurant à ça a ouvert en 2014 à Blois
un an plus tard ils obtiennent une
étoile au Michelin et c'est l'étonnement
l'étoile déjà on a été surpris de
l'avoir parce qu'on faisait un bistrot
c'était la surprise totale quand on l'a
eu si attendait pas après c'est un petit
peu plus dur parce que les gens ont une
attente supplémentaire quand on n'est
pas presse c'est un petit peu compliqué
on est très contents d'avoir les toiles
mais c'est pas une pression contraire
c'est on y pense pas on n'y pense pas le
but c'est tous les jours c'est on se
lève c'est pour faire plaisir à nos
autres c'est pour se faire plaisir avec
l'équipe les produits nos maraîchers nos
producteurs il y a plus de plaisir de la
partage des passions arrondir on se met
une pression pour
le restaurant ouvre dans trois heures
les équipes s'activent en cuisine fumico
et concentrées
une cuisine au rythme de la Loire entre
France et Japon
là
et bien sûr c'est le moment lycée fois
si c'est le de c'est le aspiration de
cuisine et
le GO Emilio a distingué foumico du
trophée de meilleur pâtissière en 2021
une nouvelle consécration pour la chef
et le couple car à ça c'est une alchimie
un partage
l'un sans l'autre on pourrait pas y
arriver on a besoin de l'un on a besoin
de l'autre moi je vais apporter on va
dire la
technique et française et les idées et
fumigo va apporter la subtilité
japonaise et la cuisine japonaise donc
on est on est complémentaire puis quand
il y en a un qui va pas le tire monte le
moral ou vice-versa on a besoin
ou sans l'autre
nourri par le fleuve nigérien le couple
foumico et Anthony Maubert propose une
cuisine délicate un voyage gustatif
d'étonnant autant que notre prochaine
chef Maria Matéos installé à buée au
pied du Piton Sancerre nous la
découvrirons dans le 3e épisode de notre
série